christina applegate reveals she's living
with multiple sclerosis
the 49 year old actress took to twitter
on monday to open up about the difficult
diagnosis
writing quote hi friends a few months
ago i was diagnosed with
ms it's been a strange journey but i
have been so supported by people that i
know
who also have this condition the dead to
me stars said that it has been
a quote tough road adding quote but as
we all know the road keeps going
unless some hole blocks it according to
the mayo clinic
ms is a quote potentially disabling
disease of the brain and spinal cord
central nervous system and other celebs
like selma blair
jack osborne and jamie lynn zigler have
been public about their battle with the
disease
it's a very unpredictable disease and
every day is a new day
with it i have to take every day like a
blessing
jack has been very open about his health
journey even creating a web series
you don't know jack about ms to provide
insight and resources to people living
with the disease
i think breaking down the stigmas for
one
around ms and giving
newly diagnosed people the confidence uh
in that in knowing that it's not game
over
and and i think uh i know her from
personally speaking i get a lot from
meeting people who've gone through the
same thing as i have and i and i hoped
it
can kind of continue to pass that on
selma decided to share her diagnosis
after having a difficult time getting
dressed during a wardrobe fitting in
2018.
later during an interview with vanity
fair she expressed her wish to make an
accessible clothing line for people who
suffer from similar struggles
and when eti talked to her long-time pal
clothing designer christian siriano in
2019
he said he was down for a collab i hope
we can figure out something she really
wants to do something i think
we just have to wait until she gets a
little better that we can like actually
really talk about it
and back in 2016 jamie lynn opened up to
et about returning to work after
revealing
her years-long battle with the disease
you know it's sort of like a gas tank
and you have your
amount of energy for the day and you
just sort of allocate and
use it where you know you're going to be
needed so i rest when they need and
you know i'm here and ready when they're
when the cameras are rolling
but this isn't the first time christina
who is mom to a ten-year-old daughter
sadie with her husband martin lenoble
has been open with her fans about her
health the actress was diagnosed with
breast cancer in 2008 and
later that year had a double mastectomy
it was awesome to get
cards and emails from people that i've
never even met before you know who are
in my business and
people who aren't in my business and
just letters from people the double
mastectomy saved her life at age 36
after her breast cancer was detected by
an mri
the thing is you can't be afraid but you
have to be
aware you know like i said if you are
what i've always said is
if you're high risk you kind of need to
be smart about it and that's
that's my whole charge out there and to
bring awareness that's not just a
disease for women over 40 it's not
now christina's foundation right action
for women
offers free mris for high-risk women
the thing that touches me the most is
when fans send donations to my
foundation which is called right action
for women
and that to me is just the biggest like
support you could possibly do
and it just you know you have to take
something bad and make it good
you